[Music]
anybody got like a
smart home or like smart speakers at
home i did i unplugged that [ __ ] [ __ ]
that
i want google listening in all my [ __ ]
all your stuff is google based no i had
like google home and i was like i would
only use it for like tell me the weather
and like play music in case i was like
cleaning or something how about alexa
yeah yeah it listens because then i'd be
like i mean my phone aside my phone's
doing the same thing but like i'd start
getting like random like i wouldn't have
my phone on me and i'd be talking to a
friend about like oh like um i want to
buy like a pillow or something like that
i'm just getting like these [ __ ]
recommendations for pillows and [ __ ] all
of a sudden and i'm like i don't like
that i don't like that at all
you you have one
you do this cool thing he's so i was
skyping with him like two nights ago and
he's like
siri cave
and then his [ __ ] room like turns on
like it has a different lighting
you have cave lighting i know i i just i
i this guy [ __ ] a lot bro
this guy is
you can name your different rooms in
your house because if you have a smart
home then you want you need to identify
different areas so if you want to like
light a room or whatever so it's not
like i'm going to be like like casey or
light the second bedroom or the downs
that's just so long so i like name rooms
right so i'll call some place like the
cave so that's where i that's my cave i
worked there you know dude i was like
god damn that's the [ __ ] palace i got it
though there was one time where i
definitely [ __ ] up i thought it was
like smooth because one of my other
homies did it and then i had my smart
lighting and then like you know i was
about to get it on with my girl and then
i was like i was like hey siri turn the
lights red right and then everything got
red she's like what the [ __ ] is this
stop change track now ruin the whole
thing
why did it make it look like a demon
looking really hard okay dude i don't
know it was lauren's cow lord scott will
tell you this when he comes back up he
used to have this thing where first of
all every time we [ __ ] when we live
together he just never closes his door
he never he never closes his door when
he takes a [ __ ] never closed his door
when he showered oh he's one of those
guys he never wore underwear and he also
air dried he never used a towel it's the
most ridiculous [ __ ] we'll talk about
because
you know it's just hilarious though
right just super open like that it's not
very efficient he's also he's
you joking around me being a sex tower
this is like the true a true sex habit
this [ __ ] is a square there's a
dragon slayer slays puss like so hard
is a [ __ ] i knew that guy was a
little pussyhound bro i've heard that so
many times from so many different people
where you you see lawrence and he just
seems like uh like not someone that
stands out but then the dying pieces
that he brings in and slays he's a
[ __ ] dragon pieces and also just the
stories they're so epic like i would
totally really be almost getting in
trouble for time he got [ __ ] caught
at a party one time [ __ ] small girl
under a pool table oh [ __ ] in the like
the party environment
how do you [ __ ] on her pool table tubes
are so thick dude you're a legend
he's a small guy he's a dragon slayer
the red light worked for him because
he's like a real sex ever i tried it
because i was inspired and it's [ __ ]
[ __ ] phony quick story i was trying
to have sex with nikki the other day and
like it was like during the daytime or
whatever and we were like you know in
the middle of it and then we looked over
at our kitty tree and our [ __ ] fat
yellow cat joe was like sitting there
staring at us like he was a cuckold
and we were like
we were like [ __ ] this
did you tell him get the [ __ ] out of
here not doing it just ruined the movie
it completely ruined the moon we're like
nope we're not having you didn't want to
like go to another room or something i
was done
the cat's like he's like
did he have one of these too
no it was just like cheshire
it was like i was ruining his life like
i was ruining his marriage
he was getting cooked is that the one
that pees on nicky that's one of the
piece on nikki that's oh that's why [ __ ]
that cat you should've [ __ ] nicky
right then in there dude but i bet you
never heard the story about bart's
threesome with his dog licking his balls
oh i have that i've heard that that
don't count as a threesome that's a true
threesome i'm a player
his first threesome that's on his body
count he's like my dog frost dude bart
has threesomes on the right species guy
you know
with that being said though um and what
i was gonna comment on yours is that uh
apparently they don't listen it's not
about a listening thing it's about like
an algorithmic like peg about like
different people's interests and if you
enter the same radius as like other
people that have shared interest that
like links to like the way that you have
like previously searched for stuff it
continues to push your interest onto
theirs as well that's weird that's kind
of creepy too it's like that's still
weird anthony it's still weird but are
you guys getting
um girls in bikinis and motorcycles on
your feed
no oh your feet is lit though i have to
admit you've shown me your feet let me
see your feet dude i want to see it's
just girls in bikinis motorcycles bikes
and now it's been wooden jewelry
what the [ __ ] is wooden jewelry dude i
do i got this from a native hawaiian man
do you wear it
why doesn't he wear it joe has props for
everything he's got the [ __ ] maui
necklace from moana this shit's [ __ ]
handmade dude [ __ ] look at this
wouldn't you that's the hook of maui bro
you're a demi god man that's actually
really tight somebody's looking for that
in the [ __ ]
heart of watiti or whatever
i got it from a hawaiian man one man
named ruben was it a gift or did you buy
it
the great hawaiian man reuben
he was a hawaiian man named reuben
[Laughter]
pretty cool right that's dope that's
sick
made dude it looks like you should do
show and tell on this show oh yeah we
should we should that should be a
careful boys episode more like joe intel
hey
i still think i pitched this we do joe's
porn emporium and he takes us through
his porn
on patreon it's too personal i
understand
they're actual personal videos
he's got his own pornhub account he's
like he's actually killing it on there
better than jk
he's a pouring up taste maker taste
maker he's a whale he's always one of
the women oh yeah he uses it so much
ben's craft does playlist for the boys
playlist for the boys of like it's like
a dj for porn yeah like like you got to
start with this
i consume porn the way that i eat food
it depends on how i feel
wipe yourself up no it depends on how i
feel that day this one's for the five
minutes and under oh
pleasure myself for an hour yeah no it's
it's like it's like i'm feeling in oh my
room's dirty i'm in the maid mood today
i gotta look at made porn environmental
that makes sense brilliant yeah it's
just i have a different feeling you know
like
yeah you're talking like a dj i like it
i get what you're doing i like it right
i like the move i like it like you're a
poor taste maker dude christmas that's
why you know the festive porn goes out
for the guys that are really into
christmas [ __ ] you know
you know guys
it's october [ __ ] 21. you got any
halloween for you got some horror
reports everyone skips over halloween
though fucktober dude october is like
one of the best times
it is because that's when everybody's a
[ __ ] mm-hmm oh [ __ ] yeah you're right
you are kind of right yeah
anyway so a woman finds that amazon has
thousands of recordings of her all from
home devices [ __ ] called it yeah
[ __ ] call she goes she goes on
tick-tock how does she find it is amazon
alexa well yeah amazon's a live stream
there's so many stories about this is
she hot i'm gonna allow you to judge
because here's the thing we all know
that there are some people out there who
probably aren't being recorded by amazon
as well
but i have a sneaking suspicion that
perhaps this person with thousands of
hours on the cloud
is pretty hot oh really yeah let's see i
want to see if this theory stands up
okay wait uh like you're talking like
what's what's your threshold like what's
what are we scoring this as to be to be
spy worthy uh like uh bart's threshold
is uh if you within if she's a 10 within
five seconds you bust a nut and if she's
uh yeah are you hitting it from behind
yeah you're busting out within 10
seconds that's bart's that's the bart
scale you can't even control yourself
that's how hard but you're saying that
only 10's get spied on are you saying
that like seven high likelihood that
she's closer to ten
than a five i think i think all right
and one is like you could last two hours
because she's of ugly please don't be a
[ __ ] the one is your dick
falls apart and then it gets soft in the
middle and then you don't even you
become a monk because you don't want to
have sex you look down and your dick
ages a thousand years and then crumbles
off into dust that's number one number
one is indiana jones abuser
that's a great you feel sexually
assaulted for having one having sex with
them okay i [ __ ] care boys i pray you
guys do not say anything like a one all
right hey yo dude that's a 10 bro
[ __ ]
[Laughter]
i have been live debunked i was debunked
yeah and sometimes you got to shoot your
shots i was debunked what are you
talking about i just nutted man she's so
hot i tried out of theory it didn't work
out
and it's okay the beautiful thing is how
average it was yeah it's just his face
being like
[Laughter]
wait so is it a human being spying on
her or is it somebody what is it a human
being i was like that's rude that's
[ __ ] wrong human being don't [ __ ]
with me man
so this woman was shocked to discover
how much information amazon had
collected on her from just a few devices
okay she says that
well uh in terms of just a few she says
she has two dots and one echo plus a few
smart bulbs that's a lot oh wait okay
but the bulbs can't listen to you what
are the dots what do you think they're
just like
like a little [ __ ] it's like a hockey
puck what's the point of them because
i'd like to see yell at it and be like
amazon turn my room red is that is that
the only dot is a smaller a
cheaper version where you can have voice
uh smart home voice activation you can
connect that to either bluetooth or like
you know audio video stereo and stuff
like that in order to have like a larger
presentation or whatever but ultimately
it's just to enhance your house and have
smart like the big feature of having all
this stuff is so you could be like hey
alexa play so-and-so song or something
or cave like like anthony's move
that's pretty much the only appeal right
well you can set shopping lists you can
ask for the weather you can play a song
you can set an alarm or timer for when
you're cooking you can set an alarm
clock to wake up you can remind yourself
to do xyz at a particular moment depends
on how smart you want your home to be so
you could even have it set up to the
point where it
attracts your algorithm so like let's
say you always exit through the garage
you always open the fridge or whatever
yeah you can set it to a point where as
once it learns your behavior you can
come down the stairs and the lights will
light up as you're going i love that
[ __ ] and when you or when you get to the
garage door the garage door opens by
itself like see all the electronics are
playing a symphony i want the door to
open too [ __ ] yeah yeah yeah dude i'm
out you can get that you don't want
robot servants no dude because all the
stuff that they're saying that they have
on the dot i could do on my phone i get
the timers here i can [ __ ] make lists
over here nick is bumming me out today
guys i gotta say he doesn't want to see
the world's largest titties he wants
nothing to do with it
nothing to do with it
he doesn't want to smell that's not my
appeal bro he wants to be woken up by
being throat [ __ ] yeah but that's
that's how i want to be working i like
it is that too much
that's what i got out of today he likes
to be thrown [ __ ] awake well those
are the big ones
[Laughter]
why is it so big wait the amazon's been
listening to her
[Music]
you